this means no longer be played on
youtube ist ein video kann von nun an
nicht mehr auf youtube gespielt werden
verfehlt hat willkommen zu einem neuen
video heute die beleuchtet wird es ein
bisschen ernster werden in diesem video
denn etwas passiert war sie offiziell
ich mache es kurz und schmerzlos oder
fieber blau außen rum ich habe fünf
claims auf meinem kanal erhalten fünf
claims jetzt fragen sich wahrscheinlich
einige von euch okay was in claims ist
das was schlimme was bedeutet das
eigentlich claims sind eine maßnahme auf
youtube mit der man dagegen vorgehen
kann das andere inhalte von einem selbst
verwenden wenn zum beispiel irgendein
minecraft let's play sumo hd x3 ist
morgen losgeht ok und erlebten video von
mir eins zu eins hoch dann kann ich sein
video klemmen weil es eigentlich mein
inhalt ist und kann so gegen sein video
vorgehen und das ist mir einfach
passiert mich einmal sondern verdammte 5
was nicht 6 x 6 x ich hatte nie mehr ein
ist noch eine reine kommen einfache text
lebens auf einem kanal
darüber möchte ich heute mit euch mal
ein bisschen redet auch darauf ein
gemacht eigentlich bedeutet wenn man
clean
also diese sogenannten claims sind
werkzeuglos dafür da hätten sich dagegen
zu wehren dass andere leute inhalte von
einem verwenden um mich an ein fachtext
claims getroffen liebe leute super das
war heute mittag leute haben meine mails
reingeschaut und das ist eigentlich
nicht reinschauen okay ist es ja diesmal
aber mein youtube mail da schaue ich
eigentlich nicht rein ja ich bin
domaschka aber ich schaue da hat mich
rein waren okay mittag da rein und habe
so nähe von youtube auch noch eine menge
von youtube noch eine mail
noch immer steht drin in allen sechs
mails steht dir video have been claims
und ich dachte was ich jetzt sechsmal
claims dass man nach drei claims nicht
gelöscht ist der kanal die automatisch
weg das ist glaube ich auch so dass die
meisten denken dass man nach drei claims
einfach weg von der bildfläche ist und
das stimmt gar nicht kennt so versuchen
wir meinen kanal einfach zweimal
gelöscht worden unterschied gemerkt
hatte es gibt aber eine andere maßnahme
die wenn die drei mal gegen eingesetzt
wird dazu führt dass der kanal
tatsächlich gelöscht werden kann und das
sind trikes aber das ist eine andere
sache als claims okay also streiks
claims nichts gleich gehen wir's mal
darauf ein was diese claims für mich
bedeuten diese fünf klären teilweise
muss ich sagen sind ja auch schon
gerechtfertigt okay ich gebe es auch
einfach zu zum beispiel habe ich in
paris nicht gemacht was ich
nie gemacht habe da nimmt man irgendwie
combination laut die sich an erzählt
irgendwas drüber und der kann natürlich
der dem die compilation gehört sagen das
ist meine compilation finde ich so nicht
okay ich mache was dagegen ich kann
jetzt ein video und das ist mir
tatsächlich passiert in den allermeisten
dieser claims ist das relativ glimpflich
verlaufen das heißt dort passiert ja
irgendwie das video gesehen haben sich
gedacht okay das ist mein inhalt ich
klemme das und dann bekomme ich ab dem
moment wo es klemmt habe wo ich mich
drauf gesetzt habe gesagt das gibt mir
das video wieder alle einnahmen also
irgend jemand in den usa sagt hey das
motto william und erkennt ihr mich und
ab dem zeitpunkt wo mich geklemmt hat
setzte sich darauf auf dieses video und
kriegt alle einnahmen die dieses video
erzählt und ich verdiene ab dem
zeitpunkt mit dem video keinen cent mehr
das ist ein paar mal passiert ich kann
mich immer so ne mail zeigen die menge
kommt von account strich no reply
youtube.com hsk corporate news content
id claims von materie linie video du
kleiner abgepackte wurst toaster
hathaway in all dem trubel in die
accounts technik ist effekte beide ok
irgendwie hat das video gefunden und
derjenige sein inhalt der möchte gerne
das ganze geld das siege verdient haben
weil er sagt dass seine inhalte nutzen
in dem fall ist es auch okay das war so
ein versuch nicht wegzuschauen videos
ist okay aber ich hab noch einige andere
mails bekommen leute zum beispiel die
hier wieder wunderschön von account
strich know that you tube altholz
accounts triplett youtube.com psk konto
[Applaus]
wobei das war ein fall aber leute das
war nicht genug nein wir haben eine
ganze fülle an fällen die leute
durchgehen können e mail sich alle
zeigen kann beschleunigt man die nächste
verdammte e mail reinalter stellt das
vor ich saß heute mittag da ich dachte
mir mein schwein pfeift stelle mir vor
sechs mail von youtube übrigens ein
video wird geklemmt
der kanal in dem fall nicht weg ist aber
dass trotzdem kraft zu sehen bei youtube
mir persönlich von wichtig ist und sie
war eine elektro steht jetzt aber die
füße still halten auch wenn sechs weimar
kommt das ist schon ein hammer dann
schauen wir drauf leuchtet das ein
echtes absolut
highlight von allem accounts riepler
youtube schreibt mir wieder und zwar hfk
youtube copyright klemm youtube video
have been blockt also wegen einem
urheberrechts anspruch der gemeldet
wurde holt ein youtube-video geblockt
wird
der videoplayer und youtube das heißt
ein video kann von nun an nicht mehr auf
youtube gespielt werden und das ist klar
das ist anders als bei den anderen bei
den anderen machst du okay kommt das
video weiterlaufen wenn ihm einfach nur
alle werbeeinnahmen
aber in diesem fall haben sie mein video
runter genommen es kann nicht mehr
abgespielt werden und zwar auf ganz
youtube nicht und welches video war das
deutlich ist es gerade schon ich habe
einen fehler auf youtube und das ist das
highlight lane bietet entertainment
digital entertainment ist ein indisches
netzwerk leute haltet euch fest in
diesem video ich habe einen fake auf
youtube habe ich aber sowie typ gesucht
was ist also gibt eine ski und es gab
einen indischen film kanal der fkg und
dann sind diese in da auf mein video
gekommen okay das ist keine automatische
sache die haben das video gesehen und
haben danach von hand gesagt hey wir
möchten das melden irgendwo in indien
sind leute ist von einem filmstudio das
sgh auf meinen kanal gekommen haben
dieses video gesehen habe dachte ich
kann zwar kein deutsch aber der typ
macht ich glaube ich überall und haben
dann gesagt was wir nehmen das wieder
runter wie absurd ist das denn aus
indien aus fucking medienleute das
gibt's doch nicht klappen
[Gelächter]
das ist echt die absolute härte leute
ich weiß auf jeden fall dass irgendein
in dem ein video gesehen hat und mein
video nicht so cool fahren wer kann das
schon von sich behaupten okay wie viele
inder haben schon von euch videos
runtergenommen halten schreibt meine
kommentare wie viele von euren videos
schon von indern herunter genommen wurde
schreibt das bitte mal zusammen gefragt
was bedeutet das jetzt für mich okay ein
video ist nicht mehr verfügbar leute
kritisch das video kann nie wieder
gesehen werden mit fünf weiteren videos
verdient jetzt kein cent mehr sondern
die gehen dann irgendwelche andere
netzwerke aber es ist okay ist alles
okay bis auf diesen einen inder
allerdings schnappe ich mir vielen dank
fürs zuschauen soweit leute hier oben
könnt ihr ein persönlich für euch
empfohlen das video anschauen hier und
man kann abonnieren und hier oben sollte
absolut spezial die neueste folge was
das geht vom ein format mit unitymedia
abchecken vielen zuschauern zwei lauern
seine schulzeit leute bis zum nächsten
mal macht gut